foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
appears Morgan are censor tonight an
extraordinary exclusive interview with a
premier league Superstar Ukraine's
Alexander zinchenko opens up on the
horrors of War of Vladimir Putin or
president zelenski and with his fight
for his own country and why Russian
sports stars should be banned
so tonight ITV in the dot Network bosses
are grilled by MPS and deny ignoring
Philip scopeville's affair with a young
male colleague but can we trust them
plus JK Rowling blast one of the top
universities in the United States after
it redefines a lesbian as a non-man
attracted to non-me
what is this garbage we will talk about
that on air
[Music]
live from on the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored Premier League
footballers often get a bad rap we call
them I've called them pampered prima
donnas and overpaid wasters we say
they're selfish arrogant lazy they're
also very often accused of being boring
media coach to the eyeballs afraid to
speak their minds well Alexander
zinchenko is an antidote to all of that
he's someone I greatly admire on and off
the pitch she plays for my beloved team
Arsenal and after tonight I think more
people were buying two I sat down with
him earlier today for what turned out to
be an extraordinarily passionate raw and
emotional interview about the war in
Ukraine about the impact on all
ukrainians like him it's already Making
Waves across the world we didn't talk
much about football there wasn't time we
spoke a lot about his homeland a lot
about the war
I've got more than 50 captures national
team he's captained his national team
the age of 24 which was the youngest
ever to do so you like millions of
ukrainians he has friends and loved ones
over there who are facing being shelled
and bombed mutilated attacked
raped in their homes
this is all because of Putin's barbaric
form of genocide against his people
and tonight he opens up on Vladimir
Putin
what are your thoughts about Vladimir
I don't want to even say his name he's
lying to himself
or whether he would go to war himself
you would fight for Ukraine
of course of course
and why Russian and Belarusian athletes
should be banned from international
sport
they shouldn't be allowed to compete
shouldn't be allowed this is not
political you that's life and death This
Is War
and why he won't shake hands with any
Russian footballer
if you had to come up against a team and
had a Russian player would you shake
that no chance
well it was extraordinary ordinary stuff
I've got to say one of the most powerful
interviews I've done in a long time was
an incredibly impressive young man it
was gripping it was heart-rending it was
shocking he just come back from his
first trip to Ukraine since the war
started and the impact of what he saw
was very real it's the kind of thing you
don't often see from a superstar
footballer frankly but I'm glad that he
opened up to me and I'm grateful for his
time and we'll be showing a lot of that
interview later in today's program the
first let me knows talk to the presenter
Nicholas Thorpe and talked to the
contributor Esther crack was abrasive
talk TV is
her Summer's Here Estrada noticed with
your outfit
it's too hot to be fully to be fully
clothed in Winter Garden of course it's
always too hot to be fully clothed in my
estimation otherwise life gets very
boring all right Nicola uh let's talk
first of all about Boris Johnson yes
tomorrow we're told we're going to get
this privileges committee report it's so
damning he's already quit and he's now
been spending the last three days
throwing his toys out of a junk gigantic
prank yeah which indicates to me that
he's feeling very beleaguered and
possibly thinks this report is so
damning that there may not be no way
back for him can we hope this or is he
like a boomerang or every time you throw
him away back he comes I mean we can
hope and pray I'm I'm actually praying
that the Speaker of the House decides to
remove his parliamentary pass as a
result of everything that's gone on as
they did with John burko of course we
need to remember that Boris Johnson
didn't have to resign wasn't necessarily
going to be the outcome that he would be
suspended longer than 10 days it would
have had to first go to the MPS then he
could have taken a petition to his
constituents but he threw his toys out
of the pram and then three minutes
before midnight I believe on Monday he
made another submission to the
Parliamentary committee they've now
reviewed that I think it's well overdue
that we get the results of this Boris
says let people judge the report for
themselves well yeah we will yeah we
will I mean Esther he's come out
fighting today because Bernard Jenkin
one of the people on the Services
committee was apparently a some party
himself during the the lockdown periods
therefore he says he's a hypocrite
therefore he should resign therefore of
course nothing this report does it's
very trumpy the thing is he could be
right right if if it's proven that he
was actually at a party fine he has
broken the rules but it shouldn't come
from Boris right this man has no
principles to speak of I mean he
allegedly resigned in Prince like for
his principles but he has none he has no
principles he has no convictions he's
clearly not taking responsibility for
what's happened and really it's in the
interest of the conservative party to
distance themselves from him as quickly
and as efficiently as possible don't
even mention his name because I think
it's a complete disrespect to the
country for what he put this country
through whilst you know what's amazing a
bit like with Donald Trump he still
carries this large number of people that
like him well he's such a narcissist and
actually the naughty of the stuff the
more they like him it's like they are
he's like a magnet to naughty moths
right it's like the worst he behaves the
more damning the judgments the worse the
stuff that comes the yeah so some people
think he is but I don't I don't think
that'll ever be again the majority of
the country well that's the key thing
isn't it yeah yeah um all right let's
turn to ITV so um you had all the bosses
hauled down there by the House of
Commons uh Select Community today over
this Phillips Schofield Scandal I was
apparently the first question so we
might as well listen to it
Piers Morgan said and I quote everybody
at ITV knew what was happening somehow
you and perhaps Holly Willoughby were
the only ones who did not know the
people that have
said they knew would only have heard
rumors about it if any one of the
individuals you have named or referenced
had come to us and said there is
evidence that there is a relationship
between Phillips Schofield and person X
we would have with evidence we would
have been able to launch a formal
investigation
so it's quite interesting this uh Nicola
because Dame Carolyn McCall there was
supposed to take her word for all this
right I can only go on what my
experience with her was when I left Good
Morning Britain where she has repeatedly
said since then Meghan markle's letter
to had nothing to do with my departure
that's just a Brazen lie I know that
because she's told other people and
everything to do with my departure so I
I'm dubious about the veracity of what
she says but on the investigation
here's what I think about that they said
their investigation basically
constituted asking Philip Schofield and
this young Runner are you having a
relationship to which they both
repeatedly said no that's not
investigation isn't it I mean everyone
the whole when I said the whole building
knew everyone was
well the young man had gone to the
National TV award and he broken down
after a few drinks and told everyone on
the ITV box I'm in love with Phillips
Philly this was the secret so the idea
that their investigation began and then
with well are you doing it no that's not
an investigation but I understand the
position that she's in is a difficult
one because she said today that they'd
investigated it or they'd spoken to both
of them 12 times and as Esther said two
people deny that they're in a
relationship there's very little that
they can do is it an egregious offense
for a guy in his 50s to be having a
relationship with someone age 20 at work
I mean in the old days 40 of of
marriages began in the workplace
normally with an older guy and a younger
woman just historically well I don't
think it's an egregious offense actually
I I do think that this the nature of how
we've been even in talking about this is
completely inappropriate we should be
talking about his wife who he lied to
and his his daughter well that's his
business and what but the thing is but
that's that's what I think is actually
more well that is his business I'm not
quite sure what the cry it's so bad
apparently that that everyone agreed
Philip schofield's entire career had to
be destroyed and yet I'm not seeing
evidence of a serious crime I'm seeing
him you know he's got a personal
struggle with his sexuality okay other
people do
um he's had a relationship right it's
inappropriate yeah okay uh where's the
crime here yeah there's no crime there
but it is an abuse of power if somebody
at not just that age but that level of
power within the alleged victim hasn't
said that yeah they haven't said what
sorry the alleged victim hasn't
complained no but ultimately and hasn't
made any protests about these so-called
abuse of power so my question is they
have decided it is but it sounded like
very there's no complaint from the
supposed victim no but it sounded very
much like a mutual agreement that they
realized that his position was
Untouchable because of the denials over
the relationship well that's not really
what is borne out by what they said in
the committee they actually said uh that
he got promoted to new job at least
women Maybe
the more Bombshells the more we don't
hear contradictions of schofield's story
I'm just curious whether people do think
what he did was a hanging offense you
may not like it you know I don't
particularly think it was particularly
edifying you shouldn't have done it but
end of a career shamed vilified you know
put on the old pitchforks I don't know I
think it's because Philip got him his
job at you know ITV and that's where the
abuse of power comes in because she's
powerful enough to get him through the
door he's powerful enough to manipulate
his career in that way but it is legal
the the the man in question hasn't said
anything illegal happened if we can even
if you can argue that it was
inappropriate it's not illegal okay uh
you're gonna come back later Pat we're
going to play my interview with
Alexander uh zinchenka now it is in
extraordinary interview so we're gonna
watch this and then you guys can comment
about it later and I'll talk to you
about the latest loaded vote woke virtue
signaling nonsense because it's right up
your alley
[Music]
ha
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook and our sensor
now to an extraordinary exclusive
interview with Ukraine and Arsenal
Superstar Alexander zinchenko it's not
very often you get to hear a premier
league star talking like this Adam
Putin's brutal war in zinchenko's home
country of Ukraine has wrecked countless
lies but many people with his profile
prefer to shy away from talking about
such contentious things he's not one of
them he's chosen to use his platform to
Rally support for the people suffering
in his homeland and to condemn the
people responsible for him he was
speaking of course in a personal
capacity but he didn't hold back
Alex thank you so much for agreeing to
talk to me I've wanted to talk to you
ever since this war in Ukraine started
and particularly so since you came and
joined my club Arsenal which I've
supported all my life
because to watch a player like you
having to go on a football pitch
twice a week
with all this going on back in your home
country
shows me you must have incredible mental
strength how difficult has it been for
you
well um thanks a lot for this in
addition it's a it's a really pleasure
to talk to you and um I tell you
honestly I I'll be honest I'll try to be
honest
um
it was not easy you know to adapt on
this
but unfortunately unfortunately
all of us I'm talking about football
players and
which is playing abroad
is not easy you know to be to be far
away from the home and then watching all
these scary things which is happening
but
um
I remember quite well
first couple of weeks that I just lost
my head I I didn't know where I am I
didn't know where I'm driving to to to
to the training ground or where I didn't
know honestly I was like in this space I
couldn't believe that that this has
happened
and uh
but in the end you know
there is two options you just
keep being in the space
or you have to do your best to help to
help your country to help Ukrainian
people
um as much as you can you have to
represent your country in the best way
you could so
that that this is the conversation was
between all of us broad players which is
playing from the national team and uh
obviously that was my uh my decision to
to carry on to to to do my best and to
help as much as I can because I know
that I'm well will be much much more
helpful to my country and to the people
from here rather than being there but I
really want to be there when did you
know that Russia had invaded your
country well it was a deep night
I was sleeping because I had session in
the morning and my wife suddenly woke me
up and she said you
started I said what started she was
crying you know like full in tears and
that what started what's wrong and she
just showed me the the videos the
pictures of of this invasion
so that's how it all started and that's
how I obviously you know if you look at
a bit back
the the the
look let me let me let me be clear some
some of the people still think or they
still talk that this is a conflict
between two countries but this is not
conflict this is a proper War right and
this war started in 2014.
when I was like 17 or something right
and I didn't I couldn't even understand
what was what's going wrong and um
they took Crimea and donbass without any
resistance and you were playing a
shakhtar Donuts yeah time and you
couldn't play right well uh all shakhtar
moved to the other city but I had
another story Football story which we
can speak later a bit but I'm talking
about just the general Invasion and they
took Crimea and donbass without any
resistance in 2014 and no one no one
could understand what's obviously
happened
um
and then obviously in 2022
since the the main Invasion across the
whole Ukraine
scary to be honest it's scary I still
cannot understand For What to achieve
what I mean it was terrifying to watch
it and I'm not Ukrainian I can't even
imagine what it must have been like for
you and your family to watch your
country being illegally invaded and in
such a brutal barbaric manner where very
quickly Russian forces were committing
atrocities war crimes you know I went to
Buca when I went to to Ukraine and heard
some of the stories there of the
appalling Massacre there
to actually be Ukrainian and watch these
scenes must have been an appalling thing
imagine the place where you was born and
raised you know every single Stone there
you know everything around yourself
you know the people around yourself you
have some some friends I don't know job
and then one day
someone from the other countries with
the guns coming there destroying
everything around raping
your I don't know your woman kids
killing men
and then
living
stealing everything around everything
would you achieve what you I don't know
what you bought before
no reason
you reckon in 2022 this is possible
I don't I don't know
but it is
and you know using this kind of
opportunities even to talk to you
I would like to to send another message
to the rest of the world I know some
people have got fatigue
I know this
um
but why it's so important to keep going
to keep pushing to to stick to be to be
together to stick together and to win
this uh terrorist invasion
it's so important because today Ukraine
is a shield for all the Europe
and you never know today is Ukraine but
tomorrow it could be I completely agree
it could be your country it could be any
country exactly what are your thoughts
about Vladimir Putin
I don't want to even say his name I
don't want to even say his name or to
talk about him it's incredible honestly
just yesterday I I watched because I'm
following all the news and I watched
a short clip of his video when he was
talking to someone sitting on the table
I don't know even these people who was
there around it's like young men and
girls
and he was talking about
which they destroyed
one week ago
and he was saying that
obviously Ukraine did it
well
hundred thousand of people lost their
houses
some of them didn't survive
there there was one Zoo 300 animals
died
and everyone was talking about Ukrainian
Ukrainian counter attack I'm talking
about Army
and then he was saying in the video he
was saying Ukraine did it because
they were planning to do counter-attack
and then this dumb
make them so slow slower
and like you're just trying to put it in
your head well you are a Ukrainian Army
you want to do counter attack
and you destroying dumb
to mix your contract slower makes no
sense
and he's just saying this I was like
watching no no I need to watch it again
maybe I didn't hear properly so he's
lying to himself he did yeah I don't
know I I know that there is a proper
propaganda I know because I had
experience to playing there but I never
followed the news or whatever but
honestly like if I had some circle when
I was playing there now this circle
became to zero
I don't understand people I was going to
ask you you went and played in the
Russian Premier League for one and a
half season yeah and you did that
because of what was happening in the Dom
bass and your family moved to Russia and
you're Russian speaking of course
you must have made lots of friends in
Russia or any of these people still
friends of yours or have you had to not
a lot to be honest not a lot
um well
I know that I had this experience in my
life right
um but and some of the people from
Ukraine they don't they don't like it
obviously and to be honest at the moment
me too right but but
um I'm human being and I understand one
thing that I would like to say again
thanks to FC
UFA
for everything what they have done the
Russian team yeah where I played yeah
but that's it we've seen some Ukrainian
athletes Sports people now refusing to
shake hands with either Russian or
Belarusian
uh athletes how do you feel about that
if you had to come up against a team and
had a Russian player would you shake
that no chance no chance because I would
never accept their reaction
honestly I have to be honest
um do you think it's cowardly the the
lack of reaction
I'm totally agree with with this
reaction
it's not it is impossible it's not
there's no point to even explain it
um
that the things look you can say well
but they didn't do anything against us
or something yes they did they did how
and what they didn't react
look they have followers behind them
millions followers in social media or
whatever they have a lot of chances to
to speak out to the people which is
following them
and if you have let's say 10 million
followers in Instagram and you post some
people I don't know one picture like
stop it just you know black form stop it
some people is from this 10 million is
going to follow you they're going to
spray this as well to someone else
and it will work in the end but if no
one is going to speak out because they
scare I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry don't don't ever call us
brothers or whatever like they did it in
the past never again
that's my that's my uh Wimbledon Tennis
for example has just said they will
allow Russian and Belarusian players to
play this year having banned them before
do you agree with that decision no
chance even though she doesn't know I
don't agree I don't agree on that I'm
one of the I have one of the ukrainians
which is uh which is
which don't like to see them in in any
on the highest level in any sport so
they should just be exactly and do you
think both countries Russia and Belarus
for sure 100 they shouldn't be allowed
to compete shouldn't be allowed why
because how many bombs and Rockets been
sending from Belarus
how many listen I'm not listen I'm not
political I didn't understand anything
about it I don't understand and I would
never understand it because this is not
my area
but
this is not political you that's life
and death This Is War and they talking
about don't put politic in sport this is
not political This Is War guys you don't
do anything
to be
I'm not saying on our side on the
Justice side
extraordinary passion and eloquence from
Alexander zinchenko and says the next
exposes second half of our interview I
ask him can you crane win the war and if
it came to it would he himself go to war
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook I'm censored
and the final part of my interview with
Alexander zinchenko we're talking about
the fundraising game he's organizing to
raise cash for the war's victims about
whether he's prepared to fight himself
but first about his personal tragedies
do you know people who've lost their
lives
of course I know people friends of yours
well not like close close friends but
yes friends the people you knew people I
knew had been killed yeah killed
destroyed by bombs in their homes yeah
they didn't do anything like bad to them
but and they didn't deserve it do you
spend your entire time just checking to
see what's happening every single day I
don't know how many hours honestly it's
just what just just washing in the
morning first what I'm what I do I'm
taking my phone and checking all the
news
how does it make you feel
like I said unfortunately unfortunately
we already get used to it to this
routine and we have to be we have to be
strong you have family of course in
Ukraine yeah I mean you must worry
yourself sick about them
well of course I'm so worried about them
and I'll tell you what
the mentality of people they don't want
to live
they don't want to leave the country
even if they could
um
this is their Homeland
and I would like for sure after football
career I will be living in Ukraine
that's for sure one million percent
because I didn't even been there for two
years and now I was I had trip there
one week ago and obviously as soon as I
passed the Border
he's just my homeland
it's just my place I can't imagine what
it's like for example to have your
parents
living in a country at War when you're
here
how is that for you sort of
psychologically to have to deal with
that
well it's not easy
um
it's not easy to
[Music]
it was not easy from the beginning
um
but you know when you already in this
routine you just you're just getting
used to it and uh
the thing is if you follow all the
instructions
in terms of siren and you hide yourself
in the bunker you more or less say but
you never know because
even last night they destroyed uh they
destroyed I don't know one building in
Odessa three people died straight
so you went back to Ukraine very the
first time you've been there since the
war started
it's one thing to see video footage on
the news or on social media it's another
to be there to see the actual
Devastation when I went to Kiev last
summer to be to be able to go to places
like Buca and see what had happened and
to talk to people who've been caught up
in that who'd lost loved ones who'd been
shelled he'd had people they knew raped
and murdered I mean it was horrific what
was it like for you as a Ukrainian to go
back to your country and actually see it
well it's completely different when you
see it from the from your phone rather
than from your eyes
painful you know it's not like scary oh
because I've seen it I've seen it by by
social medias and stuff but it's so
painful it's so painful how people
um
suffering
how people trying to survive and
I don't know just it's just a simple
example
that
thanks to our president that he
made this made this happen well that
moment on the first night yeah yeah
that's what I was trying when he did
that video in his combats with guys
around him and he said I'm not going
anywhere that was powerful to me that
was the moment where the country looked
to their leader and he was going to stay
even if it many died and this is about
this story as well when
um
U.S president calling you and saying
that look I know I have information that
you target number one and your family
Target number two
please let me take you somewhere they
where they will never find you
and he said listen
I really appreciate everything what you
are doing and stuff but I don't need
taxi I need guns and bullets how you're
not going to follow this this president
how you're not gonna how are you not
gonna I don't understand what's
incredible about him is that he was
before all this he was you know five
years ago he was a TV star
it's crazy to think that this guy who
was just known on Ukrainian television
for sort of light entertainment has
become such an influential and inspiring
wartime leader isn't it
well
um yeah it's incredible stuff but uh in
the same time
I used to say
it doesn't matter what you'd have done
in the past
it's so important who you are today
and what are you doing today so
the job he's doing is honestly I have no
words about this seeing that from inside
even don't understand a lot of things
still
um
but people say he should do a deal he
should end the war bring the peace
by giving Russia
some of the land they've taken what do
you feel about that no chance listen how
many imagine imagine you lost someone
from your circle
and uh
no no let's go let's go to the beginning
I was born and raised
knowing that Crimea is and donbass is
Ukraine yeah I spent five years of my
life the most of the beautiful five
years in my life in Donetsk amazing City
amazing
and then at some point
it's already Russian how
for what
do they have do they have the do they
have rights to do that
why we should give them how many people
already been killed
how many buildings was destroyed
and why we should give them I don't
understand so you reckon you lost
someone from your circle and then in one
day
um
we're gonna do that like you said we're
gonna give them land and then you're
gonna succeed and
well
I lost one of my circle
for the reason because we were fighting
for that
and now you you gave them like this just
your reaction
just your feelings do you feel most
ukrainians feel this way they should
give an inch for sure 100 I don't know
why they still
try sending uh every single night bombs
to Ukraine during the night from 1am
till five you know where you when you
sleep so so deep
obviously why like in my opinion maybe I
can be wrong like to keep people in fear
yes to try to push people to go against
our president to let us go against our
president to stop exactly yeah exactly
so that's what they're trying to reach
and people living with that already more
than one and a half year do you believe
Ukraine can win the war I don't believe
I know
I know we're gonna win we already won
because they didn't expect what we're
gonna do they didn't expect this maybe
they thought like they're saying uh for
three days they do parrot prepared in
Kiev City Center or what they were
thinking I don't know
it's impossible to give our uh our
homeland like like this our place where
we're born and raised and to people who
say like you say they've got they've got
tired by it all they get bored if you
like
what do you say about what Ukraine needs
now in terms of Firepower would you like
to see countries like the UK who've been
very good so far but also the United
States and other countries do you want
to see them give Ukraine more Weaponry
give them more ability to win the war I
would love to see this but in the same
time what I what I know and what I well
what I can see that they're giving
everything what they can but of course
obviously you never know all of us we
will never know is it everything or is
not everything but still I would like to
say using this opportunity I would like
to say massive things for all the help
around the world and support which we
received and receiving every single day
and I really appreciate that I mean many
United Kingdom people have taken in
Ukrainian families are you grateful that
they've done that well well I'm so proud
of this moment honestly since the
invasion started the little kids used to
come to me in the shop I was thinking
like maybe they want to make picture or
something no they they came to me like
saying uh Alex we are praying for all
your people in your country and we hope
it will finish very soon so it means a
lot for me you know it means people
staying with us
how how does it been
to play football at an elite level also
were chasing the Premier League title
this season very nearly won it how hard
has it been for you
try and perform to the level that you're
used to performing at with all this
going on
look football is my life this is the
place
where I feel most comfortable myself
and this is the place
when I'm on the beach
I just forget everything around myself
I'm just in the game
enjoying these moments
and
everything from your head how you how
you behave how you react on this this
sometimes I'm losing my head from the
morning straight away seeing the news
all day don't touch me please because
they make you emotional so much so much
but now I guess I have no emotions at
all inside I'm completely empty because
I'm a sensitive person to be honest
um
and seeing all these scary things I
think I left I left it all
and um
uh you said it's hard and not hard
it's hard for the people which is
staying on the Forefront line taking
their risk of their lives every single
second
having a babies at home families wives
it's hard for them you told a story I
think about a woman who had two young
children babies
and when the dam was blown up
she died
and you had some knowledge of this woman
I think
well I I read it in the social media and
then I asked a couple of people a couple
of volunteers is it true or not and they
said yes unfortunately it's true it's
hard to read it was so hard to read and
I couldn't even believe I really didn't
want to believe in that
and I was just thinking about this for
two days and then I was calling some
some of the people which is helping
there in that region and
I said unfortunately it's true
honestly is it's it's hard it's so it's
just that image when I read that of this
woman with these two babies
and then the water was coming and she
knew she was probably gonna die with her
kids it's just it's not just
heartbreaking it's enraging isn't it
the question is to achieve what
they donate for to achieve what
you know that in that region there is a
lot of plants
growing before used to grow and now when
all water will go down it's not gonna
grow anymore
for years it's a big ecological
catastrophe massive where you come from
right now every day people are getting
killed
well all of us ukrainians we we are
praying and we're hoping that um
our Victory is not far away
and all of us you know I'm talking about
the rest of the world all the people
which is helping us and supporting us we
believe that we're gonna we're gonna be
this Invasion that's for sure you're
going to be a father again soon and you
have a little two-year-old girl
having your own child and another child
to come has that given you
something extra when it comes to how you
think about this war and what's going on
with the young kid tobacco
I'll be honest with you
when I'm playing or
seeing my daughter smile I'm over the
moon I'm straight away forgetting about
everything around myself and in the same
time
I'm just thinking about being a DOT I'm
just thinking about about the people in
there which have exactly the same kids
and then some of them
been killed for no reason
some of them didn't come back home
and
[Music]
I don't know it makes me so disappointed
I'm so disappointed have you wanted to
join the fighting yourself if there will
be a time
everyone will be there
it will be the last call or something or
wherever it will be a call we go all of
us we go here we go everyone will go you
would fight for Ukraine of course of
course but in the same time I'm just
thinking about today uh I'm thinking
about that
I'm much much more helpful from here at
the moment
but
listen you never know what's going to
happen
maybe maybe this is the last speech when
we're going to speak to each other you
never know you never know
and um
how many people already been killed
by this invasion
I I'm not seeing myself hiding somewhere
I'm not seeing myself hiding somewhere
Alex it's been an honor to talk to you
honestly thank you for your time I wish
you all the best of this game it's going
to be star-studded lots of great players
uh can we have a few names Gerard Pique
I think is playing and uh Clarence C
Dorff you've got some other friends of
yours you've wrote in Robert Perez I
hear yeah well you said already a lot of
names and
[Music]
um
to be honest uh we would like to
announce it step by step are you looking
for a slightly older Striker
are you ready are you feeling off
you don't wake up with a body like this
without a lot of hard working effort
yeah Alex I'm ready for the cool okay
let's speak with our manager let's speak
with our manager
um I'm not quite as fast as I used to be
but I'm lethal in the 60s you're like me
yeah okay so slow slow on this on the
fish
um well you said already a lot of names
but for sure there will be a lot of
Legends on the beach
and a lot of people which is which will
be able to watch it from the stadium or
even buy TV they're gonna have fun but
the main target is from this match is to
raise the funds for the for the for the
school engineering region to rebuild it
and
um
obviously apart from this this is
another powerful message to the rest of
the world that
obviously we stick together we stay
together
um
and all these people from different
International nationality I mean
different different countries they stay
with us look the the leaders from
different countries Brazil or whatever
they stay with us
so even this is another message to the
Russian civilians which is still
believing and supporting what they do
this is another message like okay you
can watch your propaganda for 20 years
on the same same TV channel and you can
believe in this but in the same time in
the end of the day you can just think
well
okay this is one information but from
the other side all the world is against
us
maybe they have a reason or maybe this
is maybe I need to find the the real
truth so you never know obviously I lost
my hope
already like long time ago I'm talking
about Russian civilians that they can do
anything I lost my hope I'm not hoping
anymore but still you never know when I
interviewed your President we ended it
with the words Slava Ukraine Slava I
wish you all the very best for you and
your family thank you so much and to
your country thank you so much I think
you're going to win
and I think that's going to be a
powerful message that dictators can't
just invade countries when they feel
like it and kill everyone they feel like
I know we're going to Village and do
what they want actually they can be held
accountable I know we're going to win
for sure
Alex thank you very much thank you good
to see you thank you
what a remarkable young man in his
mid-20s he's a footballer
but wow what an interview
came away really
giving me a lot of food for thought I'm
sure he has with you the viewers too
uncensored next to Pat will be back
looking to keep their reaction to the
interview we'll debate that argument he
made that all Russian and Belarusian
athletes should be banned from sporting
events
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
coming up on the talk ITB claims it did
not turn a blind eye to Phillip
schofield's affair with that younger
colleague but admits it didn't actually
formally investigate and 1200 migrants
arrive in small boats in just three days
and Andrew Lloyd Webber says political
correctness is stopping him from writing
that next big musical that's all at nine
[Music]
thank you
foreign
no I mean he really changed my mind on
so many different things I went into
that interview thinking that it was
right
um for Russian players to play or go in
as Independents and he spoke so
articulately I've argued that actually I
have so I've argued it my instinct was
you shouldn't ban the individuals but
when you listen to what he said yeah
it's quite a convincing argument
complete change of heart because what
are they putting on the line I've argued
I've defended people and said well what
if Russia you know causes harm to them
or their families and he would just turn
around and say well what is he doing to
my entire country in order to be an ally
you have to be all in or you're not we
think yesterday you can imagine a scene
at Wimbledon where there could be a
Russian male tennis winner okay and he
talks about him a bit cryptically in
that interview but if he was to lift it
and be presented with it by a member of
the British royal family that's a hell
of a moment for the Russians to claim a
victory right I get it but I still feel
very uncomfortable with Banning you know
people from certain countries because of
their nation's you know political stance
on many things and I also think we have
where do you stop right exactly but we
also have to remember that you know they
are not their country and you you can't
punish individuals for something that
their countrymen have done but you also
have to remember it's his country yeah
but he is something it's his friends
who've been killed it's his family who
live in Terror and I completely
understand but they're Russian victims
why zinchenko feels the way he does but
they're not necessarily agree with it
all but I understand why he feels that
way I I think that the the idea that you
can punish someone for an individual for
something their country does is is
really wrong I don't agree with that I
don't think it's going to move the
needle and I also think we have to
remember that they're Russian people on
this the other side who are also victims
of Putin's war and I don't think you're
going to get very far by trying to
convince people that you know you should
ban Russian or Bella Russia now there's
been a mixed reaction on on social media
as I would have expected but I thought I
gotta say I just thought he was so raw
and kind of articulate and emotion
charge this felt real right this wasn't
the normal PR controlled footballer
interview this was a guy bearing his
soul about something that has been the
most life-changing thing in his world
right yeah and I really think it helps
for British viewers as well we often get
fatigued with stories like this as you
said yeah a year on people are going
well you know there's only so many
images you can see and feel horrified by
but to see it through his eyes was
really really powerful I think one thing
that he said that I found you know quite
interesting was he said it's not
political like you know you're standing
to him it's War but the thing is of
course exactly that's why they're two
sides it doesn't feel political if
you're on the receiving end of the box
right you just feel like my people have
been killed yeah but he plays for you
know one of the biggest clubs in the
Premier League he has millions of eyes
on him every week he is a very powerful
tool to keep you know the attention on
this war going and I think you know I
think you should be using that I think
and they're doing this big charity game
Andre Chef Shanker another Ukrainian
football mentioned at Chelsea August the
5th as to raise money to rebuild one of
the schools that have been demolished
800 schools have been really badly
damaged in Ukraine 220 irreparably
imagine the damage to the kids education
and everything
um I want to just segue into something
far more insignificant really but it has
wide-ranging uh I think consequences if
it's allowed to carry on the John
Hopkins University a center of medical
Brilliance around the world in Baltimore
has come up with a glossary of their
lgbtq plus guide and it's redefined the
word lesbian it says that whilst past
definitions refer to lesbians as a woman
who is emotionally romantically and or
sexually attracted to other women this
updated definition uh is his apparently
includes non-binary people who don't
identify with that so a lesbian is now a
non-man attracted to non-men and yet
bazarium the same glossary a gay man is
a man who's emotionally romantically
attracted to another man
even you surely throw the towel in now I
think they just did this to wind you up
and it's worked
um no I think that what they've done
rather clumsily I'll admit is explain
that the term lesbian literally just
means for women who attracted to women
whereas gay can be used to describe
lesbians gay can mean just a man is in
love with a man or a woman who's in love
with a woman whereas lesbian is just for
women
they have airbrushed the word woman
again and we see this time and again
where medical institutions and
universities they just won't use the
word woman well yes but I am curious
because I wanted I thought that was what
the word career or homosexual Square
means everything so okay just what about
homosexual because you know homosexuals
the same yeah it's gay yeah
well
let me just agree on one thing yeah can
we not just have all these debates but
not eradicate the word woman I can't
believe I'm the one fighting this lonely
battle for you women I would argue that
we need you why is it
I need you on lots of other battles yes
I would rather you spend more just let
women be women let lesbians be lesbians
and whatever you're up to whether you're
a lesbian or a woman or a man Keep It
Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]